House of the Dragon is coming in less than
a year.
Set 168 years before Game of Thrones, this,
Targaryen based prequel show, which focuses
on the Targaryen civil war known as the Dance
of the Dragons,
will obviously have many similarities with
Game of Thrones, one of which is Valyrian
steel swords.
Valyrian steel is a form of metal that was
forged in the days of the mighty Valyrian
Freehold.
When fashioned into bladed weapons, the steel
can hold an especially keen edge, remaining
sharp forever without the need for honing.
It’s confirmed that House of the Dragon
will feature 3 Valyrian swords in season 1
with a few joining later on in the show.
Invented in Targaryen’s original home, Valyria,
these swords are of unparalleled quality.
George RR Martin says that if the two fighters
of equal skill and power met on the field,
the one with Valyrian steel in his hands will
win.
That’s how much of a change it makes.
Almost all of the legendary warriors of Westeros
have wielded it.
What makes Valyrian steel swords so unique
is that it’s extremely rare and its blades
are lighter, stronger, and sharper in comparison
to ordinary steel.
Valyrian steel, possibly formed with dragons
and definitely forged with magic and spells,
was manufactured in the Valyrian Freehold
of old.
According to legend, Valyrian steel was made
with dragon-fire and infused with magical
spells - some say with blood magic, literally
requiring "fire and blood" (like House Targaryen’s
motto).
After the Doom of Valyria, just as all the
Valyrians and their dragons (except Targaryens
and their dragons), all was destroyed, including
the secret of making the Valyrian steel.
Valyrian steel was always costly, but it became
considerably more so when there was no more
Valyria, the secret of its making lost with
the Doom.
Only the greatest weaponsmiths can reforge
swords from existing Valyrian steel, making
those remaining weapons highly treasured and
extremely rare.
However, there are still plenty of them in
Westeros and especially in this time period
of the Targaryen civil war, which includes
the two that Targaryens owned which we never
had the opportunity to see in Game of Thrones
as they got lost in meantime.
So let’s see which 3 Valyrian swords will
House of the Dragon feature in season 1 and
which will join in the later seasons.
Targaryen’s Blackfyre and Dark Sister along
with Stark’s Ice are the 3 Valyrian steel
swords we’ll see in season 1.
Orphan-Maker, Lamentation, Vigilance, and
Lady Forlorn are the names of the remaining
Valyrian swords that will appear by the end
of the series.
Let’s start with the most famous of them
all and possibly the most legendary of them
all, House Targaryen’s Blackfyre.
Blackfyre is a Valyrian steel sword that originally
belonged to Aegon I Targaryen, Blackfyre is
a fabled hand-and-a-half longsword of Valyrian
steel once wielded by Aegon the Conqueror
during the Targaryen Conquest of the Seven
Kingdoms.
Afterward, it became the treasured ancestral
blade of House Targaryen, carried by kings
and princes.
During the story of House of the Dragon, and
therefore during the Targaryen civil war,
it belonged to Aegon II.
Aegon II Targaryen's possession of Blackfyre
enhanced his legitimacy against his rival,
Rhaenyra Targaryen, during the Dance of the
Dragons.
When Aegon returned to King's Landing near
the end of the Targaryen civil war, he allowed
the condemned Trystane Truefyre to be granted
knighthood before his death.
Ser Marston Waters dubbed the youth Ser Trystane
Fyre, and Ser Alfred Broome then beheaded
the newly-made knight with Blackfyre.
Before and after this, Blackfyre was wielded
by many great warriors and no doubt seeing
such a legendary sword will be amazing.
Coming as the second Valyrian sword we’ll
see in season 1 is also from House Targaryen
and as you’ve probably guessed it by now,
it’s Dark Sister.
The Dark Sister is the name of the famous
longsword of Valyrian steel once belonging
to Visenya Targaryen, the sister-wife of Aegon
the Conqueror.
A great warrior, she used it in battle as
well as riding her dragon during the War of
Conquest.
In our story, it’s used by another legendary
warrior Prince named Daemon Targaryen.
Prince Daemon Targaryen was given Dark Sister
by King Jaehaerys I for his prowess.
Ser Criston Cole defeated Daemon in a tourney
for King Viserys I's accession, knocking Dark
Sister from the prince's hand with a morning
Star.
Daemon wields Dark Sister during his war for
the Stepstones.
In 115 AC, he defeats the Braavosi betrothed
of Laena Velaryon with the blade in a duel.
During the Dance of the Dragons, and during
one of the most epic fights in Westerosi history,
Daemon fights against Aemond Targaryen with
the blade in the Battle Above the Gods Eye,
leaping from the back of his dragon, Caraxes,
to plunge Dark Sister into Aemond's eye.
When Aemond's bones were found some years
later in the waters of the Gods Eye, Dark
Sister was still thrust hilt-deep through
his eye socket.
Cannot help but think of this Daemon’s statement
that’s written in Fire And Blood book: Dark
Sister was made for nobler tasks than slaughtering
sheep.
She has a thirst for blood.
—Daemon Targaryen to Corlys Velaryon.
The Third and final Valyrian steel sword we’ll
see in season 1 of House of the Dragon is
the one you’ve already seen in Game of Thrones.
It’s House Stark’s ancestral greatsword
Ice.
It’s as wide across as a man's hand and
six feet long and taller even than Robb Stark.
The blade is Valyrian steel, spell-forged
and dark as smoke with deep rippling.
The name "Ice" is a legacy from the Age of
Heroes and predates the current sword.
About four hundred years before King Robert
I Baratheon's reign, the Valyrian steel greatsword
was spell-forged in Valyria and acquired by
House Stark, who named it after that legacy.
During House of the Dragon, it’s wielded
by legendary Cregan Stark who supports Rhaenyra
Targaryen and marches south to support her
claim.
Lord Cregan Stark will use Ice to behead all
the traitors when he arrives in King's Landing,
time in the capital which became known as
the Hour of the Wolf.
Lord Stark will also use it in his fight against
Aemon the Dragonknight who is said to be House
Targaryen’s finest warrior and about whom
you can still hear songs all over Westeros.
Those are the 3 we will see in season 1, but
later seasons will feature many more of them.
One of them is Lamentation, a famed Valyrian
steel sword that belongs to House Royce.
Ser Willam Royce wields the blade during the
Dance of the Dragons.
The sword is torn from the hand of Willam,
however, when he is killed during the Ride
of the Seven.
With Willam's death, the sword is carried
off, never to be found again.
However, some rumors claim that Ser Warrick
Wheaton slashed a wing off of Syrax with a
Valyrian steel sword, likely Lamentation,
during the Storming of the Dragonpit.
Next sword that will appear later on is Vigilance.
This Valyrian steel longsword belongs to House
Hightower.
Lord Ormund Hightower wields the blade during
the Targaryen civil war fighting for king
Aegon II.
After the Battle on the Honeywine, he used
it to knight his squire, the king's brother,
Prince Daeron dubbing him "Ser Daeron the
Daring", for turning the battle in his favor
with his dragon Tessarion.
Lord Ormund is killed by Roddy the Ruin, leader
of Stark’s elite army Winter Wolves at the
Battle of Tumbleton.
It’s unknown what happened to Vigilance
afterward.
Another sword we’ll see later on is Orphan-Maker,
a Valyrian steel longsword with a black blade
belonging to House Roxton.
Ser Jon Roxton wields the blade during the
Dance of the Dragons while fighting for King
Aegon II Targaryen and the greens.
During the Battle on the Honeywine, he used
it to deliver a fatal wound to Lord Owen Costayne.
During the Second Battle of Tumbleton, Jon
slew Hugh Hammer with Orphan-Maker, splitting
him from groin to throat.
Shortly thereafter he was killed by Hugh's
men in a ten against one fight.
The sword came into possession of Lord Unwin
Peake.
When Peake became Hand of the King during
the regency of young king Aegon III Targaryen
in 133 AC, he drew Orphan-Maker, declaring
that, unlike the previous Hand, the blind
and crippled Ser Tyland Lannister, he could
still wield a sword.
The sword's current whereabouts are unknown.
The final and one of the most legendary Valyrian
steel swords in Westeros that we’ll see
is Lady Forlorn.
It’s the ancestral longsword of House Corbray.
Lady Forlorn is traditionally passed down
from lord to lord, but examples of lords lending
the blade to a son or a brother for their
lifetime only to have it return to the lord
afterward have been recorded in the history
of the house.
Lady Forlorn has a heart-shaped ruby in its
pommel.
Its Valyrian steel is smoke-grey in appearance.
The name "Lady Forlorn" is a legacy from the
coming of the Andals, and predates the current
sword.
Robar II Royce, the High King of the First
Men of the Vale, claimed the first Lady Forlorn
after slaying Qyle Corbray, the King of the
Fingers and the Andal leader.
Robar wielded Lady Forlorn during the Battle
of the Seven Stars, using it to kill Torgold
Tollett and a decoy dressed as Ser Artys Arryn.
The Corbrays claim that Ser Jaime Corbray
slew Robar in the battle, allowing them to
reclaim the first Lady Forlorn.
At some point, the Corbrays acquired a Valyrian
steel sword which they named Lady Forlorn
in honor of the ancient sword.
Ser Corwyn Corbray, the brother of Lord Leowyn
Corbray, wields Lady Forlorn during the Dance
of the Dragons.
Corwyn, one of the regents for Aegon III,
is slain by a crossbowman at Runestone after
drawing Lady Forlorn on Lord Gunthor Royce.
Those are all the Valyrian steel swords that
we’ll see in the House of the Dragon.
The most legendary of them: Ice, Blackfyre,
and Dark Sister you’ll see in season 1 with
others coming and going throughout the series.
The Game of Thrones prequel series, House
of the Dragon, based on the book Fire And
Blood will air in 2022 on HBO.
Thank you so much for watching.
If you enjoyed this video please give it a
big thumbs up and I hope to see you in the
next one, peace!